President Trump not backing down as
outrage from the left intensifies over a
fundraiser hosted by the chairman of
equinox and solstice
in New York earlier today for the event
at the Hamptons home of CEO Stephen Ross
the outrage growing while celebrities
are cancelling their memberships and
urging others to boycott the trendy gyms
some of the media taking the attacks
even further believe it or not I'm on
pitchforks and torches outside this
man's house in the Hamptons I've been to
the Hamptons
it's very nice there's no reason why it
has to be you don't get to say for
racial equality and all these good
things I disagree with them there but I
like his economic views I'm gonna vote
for no you own it you own the blood that
happens you own shots but you can't do
it you can't you get the whole package
and that's what swing voters have got to
understand and be shamed into president
Trump responding by defending Stephen
Ross and saying the backlash well it's
gonna backfire is a very successful guy
by the way I think he's probably more
inclined to be a liberal if you want to
know the truth but he likes me he
respects me the controversy makes Steve
Ross hotter
figure that out in about a week but he's
very happy he's got a very successful a
lot of people are going I guess they're
gonna raise 11 or 12 and he was right
the RNC just put out a notice that
President Trump raised twelve million
dollars today so the campaign's awash in
money Dan you know how sorry instead of
a life do you have to have to be focused
on these endless boycotts all the time I
mean seriously go to your kids soccer
game in a baseball have some popcorn go
to a movie and here's the difference
between right and left boycotts I know
we talked about this yesterday a little
bit but you know that the right usually
boycotts things cuz people companies
don't crap all over America or because
of people's way of life things are
important you know the Betsy Ross flag
thing people kneeling in front of the
flag the left boycotts on the dumbest
things ever so you get this guy Ross was
clearly not a conservative by the way
put out a very nice statement saying
listen I don't agree with everything
Donald Trump says I engage both
Democrats and Republicans clearly wants
to get some conversation going with the
president and they sit there and they
boycott like they have nothing else to
do I mean where are the soccer moms that
they go to a soccer game dad go to a
game enjoy your life stop boycotting
everything I mean is there a list of all
the liberal boycotts the stuff is so
silly I did wonder Greg about Danny
Deutsch was saying that you owned
everything so if you supports a
politician that that means you own
everything they say that I I don't live
my life I think it's better to try to be
Danny Trejo and not be Donny Deutsch bag
because this why is this boycott
especially destructive because you're
linking innocent people to a horrific
event right and then you instigate a mob
on Twitter so what you're doing is you
create the target and you mobilize a mob
I mean this is actually mob action it's
not really a boycott it's more like get
them get these people and the great
thing apart yeah it's yeah I mean act
pitchforks he actually said it so the
great thing about the five is that we
can actually read the mood of a nation
you know what we even if we even if we
want to say certain things we wake up
every morning we ask ourselves whether
we're gonna be a plus or a minus right
we're gonna dispatch twice now you are a
plus
Plus sighs but viewers in art I think
our viewers are no different they don't
want to go to work they don't go to work
thinking I'm gonna make somebody pay and
I think at MSNBC you got to ask yourself
like do you want to wake up every
morning and makes a terrible week worse
because that's what you're doing you're
actually they're not reading the mood of
the name of the nation they're not
checking the thermostat if they check
the thermostat they wouldn't keep
turning it up and what they're doing
they're saying people have blood up
swing voters have blood on their hands
you're demonizing you're escalating the
demonization and that just makes matters
worse you could disagree with people and
wait it out and calm down but this isn't
right
it's not right what do you think about
that Donna in terms of when when people
criticize the president his supporters
tend to think that that criticism is
also aimed at and people felt the same
way when people went after personalities
media personalities went after President
Obama look the outrage machine is pretty
active on both sides I recall a couple
of months ago when I got a message that
I couldn't go to Home Depot all right
and then and why was that what was the
this was because the owner of how ripe
Oh had made a comment that he was going
to give to the president's campaign
unfortunately I was one of those people
that for years begged for Home Depot to
come into the inner city of Washington
DC and that was my go-to place because I
like to pick up dirt the real copper
rule but then I'm like oh god I have a
coupon I need to go to Home Depot before
the boycott begin afternoon I ran a home
depot and I wanted to put on a disguise
but I realized no one looks like me so
why not
I remember when some people on the right
they were criticizing Netflix they say
boycott Netflix boycott oreos like I
didn't wear I cannot boy boycott we've
gotta let Starbucks Wayfarer Nike this
is a tea the president tweeted that so
stop it the outrage machine this is free
speech when you decide to give if you
run for Congress again I might give you
a nickel or two I'm not giving you two
no way all right
but I might give you some I give I might
even throw a fundraiser because I know
you're not like you okay that's very
nice
I appreciate you think I'm scared to the
gym today you said yesterday was a
little light how about today yes still
light today as well it's the boy not
working I think it's working in I don't
care because I've been waiting for the
equinox as I always do because it's a
clean gym and that's the only thing I
care about the part that bothers me
about this entire debate is the
hypocrisy the hypocrisy saying that the
president is the only one that's
escalating things right the Democrats
and the president aren't far apart when
it comes to tone of things but it's only
one side telling the other side to calm
down I think America is at this breaking
point right now where everything is
being taken so personal the only
difference is that the Democrats like to
call the Republicans hateful people
right anytime that we like something
then we're the racist and they also are
the ones that like now as we saw on TV
says show up the people's homes with
pitchfork well we don't like something
either there's a boycott but there's not
any antagonizing coming with guns it's
like you say you don't like it and then
you